okay perfect it is time for drew's news
your daily chew on the old good news
jerky
and with me at the desk is my little
slim jim rossi rasmus
snip your friends
[Applause]
no that was um randy savage
is that did i make that name up no it
was
what was his name
macho man randy savage yeah macho man
yeah he stole my name and he said did
you give it back
i'm the only macho man in this town
well today we want you to get out that
pen and paper and take some notes
because guess what we have to do my
favorite it's a pop quiz
[Music]
yes
everyone
everyone take out your pens make some
notes because at the end of the show one
member of our studio audience is going
to play to win
we're going to ask three questions about
today's show and if they get them all
right they'll win a special prize so i'm
looking at all you all right all right
stay tuned we love games and prizes we
love it
first i want to kick it off with
something that really spoke to me it is
people magazine's people of the year
they've got four special covers
celebrating the transformative work of
we have music legend and philanthropist
dolly parton oh my gosh right come on
actress and outspoken force for change
sandra oh lord amazing olympian and
mental health advocate changer of the
world
simone files and representing america's
heroic teachers
national engineering
teacher of the year this is amazing i
literally went on dan wakeford who is
the editor-in-chief of people magazine's
instagram and just wrote thank you for
this thank you for choosing these people
and putting these big quotes on the
magazines it's impactful
it's
intelligent
joyful inspiring educational and just
all things good yes and they have all
done such great work all year long i
mean look at dolly she's a 160 million
books she's given to her imagination
library for kids donating a million
dollars for coveted vaccine
and then you know teachers can we talk
about teachers for a second my
wellington my fiance is an educator and
what they've been through during this
pandemic is unbelievable showing up day
up to date reinventing how we teach our
kids that's right people magazine thank
you for celebrating teachers thank you
for being here
when we go
to the newsstands this is what i want to
see thank you people magazine absolutely
well next we've got a report from rover
the pet sitting app used by millions of
pet owners they dug into their database
to analyze the most popular pet names of
the year well cnn entertainment reports
the very tippity top names of the year
are bella and max
yo
well they also looked at trending names
overall and it got a little interesting
here uh covet inspired names are up like
fouchy
and
how about this zoom come on zoom come on
and how about tech names tech names are
a thing too people naming their dogs
amazon
google
siri can you imagine what you get
delivered from amazon if you were like
alexa bad dog alexa did you go on the
rug
and
french names french names are on the
rise for some reason dior
caviar
dijon
and beckett come on little baguette oh
i like that guy
oh and celebrity names too you know what
the biggest one for celeb names what
people are naming their dogs britney
because
because she's unleashed
i um this irritates me what it does i
don't know why it just does i i why why
would you want more
of that
tech
ubiquity
in your life i know amazon you've got to
be kidding me can you google alexa no
can you imagine you're in the park and
some guy's just like grinder grinder get
back here
[Applause]
my my pet names i'm realizing are so
normal and tame i have lucy and douglas
the dogs yes
oh and then lucky and peach are the
cat's names named by my daughters olive
and frankie yeah we're real tame in our
house apparently well you know i have
three dogs named the name is audrey
after audrey hepburn because she's a
natural beauty and i don't even have to
put makeup on her look she's just
gorgeous um the middle one is selena
because she's voluptuous and sexy
and then the the furthest back that i
adopted him at 12 years old and he
looked like my great grandpa earl so i
named him paw earl after him
they're sensible don't name your dog
google please come on or do it and live
your bliss all right next we've got a
real heart warmer it's just one of those
fun facts that
develops into something really lovely
it's from tanks good news and it's about
a special 20-year friendship that
started by accident
it all started when gladys hankerson who
was around 60 at the time called the
wrong number when she was trying to
reach her sister and instead she got a
man in his 20s named mike moffitt listen
it was just one of those mistakes and
they got to talking and she actually had
lost her son oh and they started a
friendship and they were talking every
few weeks for 20 years
and this thanksgiving mike now 46
surprise gladys now 80 in person
and she called it the happiest
thanksgiving ever
oh
i
i know
i know so much
i really do this really speaks to me i
know
can i tell you something i answer every
phone number when it's like a number you
don't know i call it phone roulette and
i'm always picking up just because i'm
hoping it's like an 80 year old woman
out there call me call me please this is
my fantasy this is what i i romantically
look and i have all old school
telephones in my house i love a landline
so like a big button like a lot is it oh
i have like the large button in the
kitchen does it hang on the wall oh yeah
oh my gosh
with the cord do you have a time machine
so you can go back and use it i wish i
did
but every time i look at that phone i
think about what was possible with the
telephone but gladys and mike you show
me all of my dreams are possible yeah
it's a reminder there is such humanity
out there
okay rock your story uh well you know
you know if you've been watching all
week it's cookie week okay
drill has been you've been force feeding
me cookies all week long what did i do
maybe you guys maybe you've been
inspired to bake well we've got a hot
tip for you and you don't if you don't
have like a professional baker's rolling
pin in the house well kate hudson has a
festive fall solution for you i saw this
apartment therapy reports she posted a
video to instagram she's working her pie
dough
with a gourd huh yeah um so she
apparently didn't have a roller pin but
she did have a squash
and see if we can squash our dough we
have some right here i'm into this okay
i'm here for this watch
see if it works
it totally works
you guys
oh my gourd it works
yeah thank you kate hudson this is
awesome i love this
[Music]
you